hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara just saw and tonight
I went and saw spider-man into the
spider-verse spider-man into the spider
verse I got it right keep wanting to
call it a multiverse here I'll redo it
hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
this is Tamara just saw tonight I saw
the best spider-man movie ever made not
only that it's in my top three favorite
animated films of all time list I went
into this very excited to have a fun
time and I left
having had cried like three times having
had gotten the most comedy the most
story the most character development I
cannot recommend this film enough this
is the spider-man movie that I've been
waiting for since the second Tobey
Maguire phone also I've liked every
single spider-man movie that's ever come
out I loved the Tobey Maguire ones I
loved the Andrew Garfield ones and I
loved Tom Holland in this new
reincarnation of him this animated film
that focuses more on Miles Morales
however is my absolute favorites gonna
be hard for me not to spoil anything I'm
gonna do my very best if I spoil
anything
[Music]
no spoilers
I say hesitantly this story is about
Miles Morales who gets bitten by a
radioactive spider and he turns into
spider-man he then gets thrown into this
whole thing where kingpin is opening
another universe to find his family and
all the other spider-man's
come and join him in his couldn't
space-time continuum listen I didn't
take physics there's six vitamin in all
and the way that they introduce them is
so great it's unique to each one but
there's one specific thing that is the
same with all of them and it really ties
it together really well the comedy is so
so fresh I wrote fresh I think like
eight times in my notes tonight while
watching this movie it all feels so
fresh in
in a story that we've seen so many times
recently
weirdly how recently we've seen so many
different types of spider-man all being
Peter Parker but so many different takes
on it and it's so freshly done the story
is super fresh the character work is
super fresh and the animation is so so
so fresh fresh new fresh fresh fresh
it's kind of incredible though how they
were able to take something that we all
we all know and give it to us in a way
that was so palatable and it wasn't too
much touching on what has already
happened we all know what's happened and
they literally say that he's like
alright this is what happened you know
basically the rest just move on yes by
focusing mostly on miles I think they
were able to really achieve something
really great but we still we get a lot
of Peter Parker in this as well a lot of
fun touches on other characters I will
say without spoiling anything that this
is my favorite role that Nicolas Cage
has ever been in I love Nicolas Cage
this was prime Nicolas Cage like the
only Nicolas Cage you will ever desire
for us to feel like you get Mary Jane
Watson and at a distance you get Aunt
May and Uncle Ben at a distance and you
you get a lot of cool villains at a
distance and some up close and mostly
though it's focused on the heroes I
don't think the villains are cool
they're not like the front runners of
this movie but the heroes are all so so
so so well-written and it's like you
know them because you do you get the
basis of them they're all different
spider-man from different worlds and to
see them come together and you get you
get their different personalities and
their different spices but they don't
need to spend a million years talking
about what makes each of them special
spider-man you get because they're
really well-written and that's I don't
know I I feel like it it must have been
really difficult for them to do that and
they did it so well when Miles came on
screen I instantly knew
who the character was it didn't take all
of this backstory you get a sense of who
his parents are and you get a really
great relationship with him in this dad
the relationship is struggling but you
as a viewer really get to look in on
that you get the relationship between
him and its uncle you get the
relationship between him and his
classmates and he's going to this loose
school and you know him and he's not
this like valiant superhero the second
that he gets his powers and that's what
makes him great and he really just fits
right in into this world I wrote how
exciting is it to see a fresh take on
spider-man origin story so exciting the
pace was so great you know in a story
that could have had terrible pacing with
all of the different characters that you
got I felt like there were stakes in the
actual story it wasn't just about the
characters there was a real story going
on during it the animation was so
exciting so thrilling it had the same
stakes as a live-action really well done
superhero movie and that is just I it's
in my top I know I get very passionate
after I see this movies for Tara juice'
and so I always make these crazy claims
like after I saw last Jed I was like
this might be my favorite Star Wars it's
not but take this with a grain of salt
this is in my top three favorite
animated films because it's so well I
was sitting there in the theater and I
was like do I like this more than Iron
Giant my favorite animated film cuz I
definitely like it more than my second
favorite animated film just Hunchback of
Notre Dom so it was it my second
favorite animated film or my first
favorite animated film then I was like
well maybe pay attention to the movie
camera okay I won't say what happened in
the cameo this is a marble Sony film
there was a Stan Lee cameo and I mean
just floods it was so perfect it's like
they knew it was the most incredible
sentiment that they could have had him
say oh I was the tone was perfect it was
funny so sweet it was in a pivotal point
for this
I four miles it was just ten out of ten
best Stanley Carey oh I wrote I bet what
Stan saw of this movie
he loved I bet he loved this movie it
had just screamed Stanley I think out of
the villains my favorite was Doc Ock I
definitely want to cosplay as this
version of Doc Ock
she was spicy and cool and very tech
heavy and brilliant and I loved her
there's a lot of fun play with the
timeline crossovers from the different
worlds some of the same people are in
the different worlds and so when
somebody from another world meets up
with somebody in this world it's really
funny and times really touching in times
like if you're in this world and your
friend died and then you go to this one
and they're still alive that meetup is
like really fun or if you know this
person slapped you here you go back here
and you're pissed at him really funny
kind of stuff they play with it well not
too much perfect amount it was really
used effectively Lily Tomlin is Aunt May
I mean come on come I could have just
said hi everyone my name is Tara
chambers this is Tamra just saw tonight
I watched spider-man
spiderus and Aunt May was voiced by Lily
Tomlin good night and then everyone
would have flocked to the theaters
there's a specific scene where Miles
Morales fully realizes himself as
spider-man he has been that dorky unsure
self and then his a realization pops in
and he goes full force spider-man and
the music is beautiful and it's like
badass you feel super pumped up and it's
just emotional and beautifully animated
and it's the best that's another thing
the music is a really good the
soundtrack for this rules this is the
Nic Cage we've all wanted pure play at
the end even kingpin I think though it
really wasn't focused on kingpin
I felt empathy or I felt what's the word
I want to use I may be relatable I don't
know I felt like he had a really good
motivation for what he was doing and I
enjoyed seeing that they humanized him I
guess I'm gonna go see this again I text
three people after the movie before the
end and
and told them that they have to see it
immediately and then the end credits
came and the theater was laughing so
hard it's so funny it's so it's so low
stakes in the best way also there's a
mid credit thing that's not not a scene
just a really beautiful quote that again
just crying now in the light of day
because the lights had come up but just
really really nice they touched upon
everything that I wanted and more it was
funny it was emotional it was gorgeous
the storytelling and character work
we're just out of this world
I can't recommend this enough this is my
favorite spider-man film one of my
favorite animated films of all time
and I can't believe I guess I don't know
I know that it was pumped up a lot by
Marvel but I feel like I haven't heard
that much about this since it came out
it came out last Friday right I I don't
know I guess I haven't heard that much I
saw some stuff from Andre from black
nerd comedy I think that's it
go see this movie if you haven't seen it
yet it's out of this world it's so good
thanks for watching I'll see you guys
next week
probably with Aquaman Oh God bye
you